dr. Collins has already said they want
another book yeah you could do a cover
like a romance novel with like a billowy
blouse oh yeah I think what I'd really
like to do is a travel log that might on
the surface sound boring but we just did
40 gigs in the last two months in seven
countries we played Mexico City like two
nights ago and and people don't [ __ ]
get the like Kanye West gets it he's at
home in bed yeah I'm on Sirius radio I'm
tired I'm Thursday notice [ __ ] I was a
[ __ ] roll duders a glass of water how
was Mexico Mexico is good or is it scary
it's grueling yeah are you grueling if
you cancel it where you been on the road
I mean how does it knowing right cuz he
walks out of a show three songs in and
then he canceled like 30 show and we're
laying like in in sudbury in the snow
with the lifting up [ __ ] on the ice and
the [ __ ] so I'm not lifting but yeah
somebody is but he he doesn't have any
equipment he doesn't have a band he's
got not aegis him on a stage with a mic
not to be a prick but right I don't I
don't think that that guy or the
Kardashians like know what they signed
up for like in this world you know what
I'm saying it's like they don't do
anything right we're just on this name I
want to be a rock star we have a [ __ ]
nice time with that I'm gonna [ __ ]
cancel all those not as easy as you
think it is all right how do you leave
this [ __ ] hiring it's grueling my
thirsty talking about your Thursday get
a [ __ ] bottle of water you don't even
know what you're talking about right he
might have mental problems bolt that's a
luxury hey my sweet I think I'm a
[ __ ] mental [ __ ] yeah I think so does
it give me a ride to cancel the game but
Ozzy Osbourne he's real stable that's a
good point yeah i think i need awful
[ __ ] on Ozzy's up there shuffle
around pee in his pants does he earn
eight himself yeah it does if we employ
as soon as black salads done i'm doing a
nose solo record